devil fruits are by far one of my
favorite parts of all of One Piece and
apparently they are yours too because
you all submitted nearly 2,000
submissions to my devil fruit contest
and there were just so many incredible
options to choose from that I couldn't
just stop at one video so here are 20
more of the most mindblowing devil
fruits that should absolutely exist in
one piece starting with one of the most
creative ideas I've actually ever heard
of which is the the tattoo devil fruit
submitted by Ethan basically this
ability allows you to draw tattoos all
over your body and then turn those
tattoos into real life actions for
example imagine that you drew a sword
tattoo on your arm well when you need a
slicing attack you simply use that sord
Tatu and it appears as a slicing attack
to cut down your enemies or imagine that
you drew a giant pair of wings on your
back and then using that tattoo it would
allow you to fly a short period of time
in other words yeah an incredibly useful
fruit in almost any situation as long as
you have the creativity and skill to
draw many different styles now obviously
to balance this fruit out a little bit a
good restriction here is that once you
actually use a Tat's power it does
disappear from your body so no you can't
just infinitely spam that sord tattoo
that you drew that also means that
you're going to have to be careful about
which tattoos you actually use when and
also another incredible ability of this
fruit could be that the larger that you
draw the tattoo the more powerful it
actually becomes for example imagine
that you drew a wave tattoo to send out
water well if the t-o is kind of like as
big as your hand then it probably would
just be a small burst of water but then
imagine if you draw the wave across your
entire chest well then you might get a
giant tsunami to wash away all your
opponents but less space for other stuff
so yeah these are exactly the kinds of
Super Creative fruits that I love to see
that can be used in combat yes but ALS
also in so many other situations however
even the tattoo fruit would very likely
get overwhelmed by the sheer power of
the sound devil fruit submitted by Jello
boy and this is just all kinds of
powerful because this loia fruit
transforms its eater into a soundwave
human capable of becoming and producing
all types of sound waves and at first
you might be thinking well that doesn't
sound so cool but trust me this fruit is
insane because sound waves are literally
everywhere around us all the time so
basically this user can obviously send
out sound waves to make crushing Sonic
booms or they can make different voices
and sounds all around to confuse people
you also get incredible speed because
you can travel at the speed of sound but
that's not all though because if your
sound waves are strong enough they can
even act like a physical attack to knock
people down kind of like how you can
feel the air vibrating in in front of a
super loudspeaker and do remember there
are actual military weapons also related
to sound but to get to maybe the most
broken part of this fruit we do need to
dive into science here for a moment
because Recent research has revealed
that people's brains can be somewhat
controlled by certain sound waves which
is scary and so yeah an extremely
skilled user of this fruit could
possibly even influence a person's
Behavior to a certain extent however
there is one major drawback here and
that's because sound waves can be
blocked by physical objects so this
fruit can be majorly nerfed if the
target is hiding behind a wall or
something but to be fair sound travels
faster in water and there is a lot of
water in one piece and while some people
may be kept away from using that sound
fruit I can't think of anyone who
wouldn't want this next one and that's
because Pete Culver from the United
States submitted the kibo koni otherwise
known as the
wishwishwish in a bottle ability which
grants the user exactly three wishes and
man what a ridiculous power to have
because with this fruit you could
literally take over the world want to
just become the ruler of the world
government just wish for it or how about
becoming the richest person in the
entire world easy or you want to own one
of the strongest weapons in all of One
Piece done just like that but as cool as
this fruit is we just have to includes
some real restrictions here as well such
as that you can just wish for someone to
be dead no wishing for the ability to
swim since that kind of De feeds the
main weaknesses of devil fruits and no
wishing for more wishes or something
that completely breaks reality oh yeah
and you do have to be very specific
about your wishes for example if you
just wish for something like super
strength let's say well this fruit can
give you that but it might not be
exactly what you were hoping for because
sure you can have super strength but you
know maybe only four or five seconds if
you don't specify in the right hands
though and with some really careful
wishing this fruit could easily help you
take over the world but what's crazy
though is that this next fruit might be
even better than the wish fruit in the
hands of the right person because now we
have the built fruit submitted by floo
from Germany and just like it sounds
this fruit allows the user to build
anything that they can imagine as long
as they have the right materialss lying
around which honestly is so useful I
mean with this fruit if you're somewhere
like let's say Marine Ford with lots of
stone Metal Guns and swords everywhere
you could just make yourself a giant
Mecha suit full of slashing blades and
powerful guns and that's not enough for
you you could turn the stone beneath you
into a giant castle or wall for defense
but of course this fruit is even more
useful outside of battle because could
also just make you filthy rich if we're
being real for example you instantly
become the world's best Onan
Construction Company where you can just
make houses buildings entire towns or
even the world government's ridiculous
giant Bridge here with Incredible speed
however one real downside of this fruit
is that you can't really change your
available resources too much so
basically have to use what you've got
around you however just wait until you
see another power in just a minute on
this list that will make this buil fruit
look like a child's construction kit in
compar but before we get to that we have
the first of many super creative Zone
fruits with the gecko fruit here
submitted by brenon from the states as
well and this may sound a little bit
underwhelming but just listen to the
incredible abilities that geckos
actually possess first they of course
all get the obvious normal Zone
abilities like a full gecko form and a
gecko human hybrid form and along this
you get the ability to climb walls with
your sticky hands your gecko body
instantly becomes poisonous this to
touch because many geckos are covered
with poisonous slime and along with this
you can shoot out poison at enemies look
in two different directions at once and
use enhanced hearing as well but on top
of all of that there are two more
incredible abilities that also make just
way too much sense with this fruit first
lizards are well known to be able to
regenerate parts of their body so a slow
regeneration ability would make a lot of
sense here as well plus we could also
give it a camouflage power on top since
many lizards are experts at blending in
with their environments in fact that
extra stealth Factor makes it perfect
for someone like a secret agent or a
sneaky character like let's say Sanji
and still there is probably no sneakier
fruit than the next one which is the
phas phase devil fruit submitted by es
Stinger from Canada and to explain this
one basically think of yourself like a
ghost where you can just turn your body
into an Untouchable substance this
ability would basically let you walk
through walls with ease sink through the
ground and pop back up in another place
and even make yourself immune from most
regular attacks since they would just
pass straight through you and man can
you just imagine someone literally
popping out of a wall or the ground it
would be like the ultimate jump scare
ability and on top of that it's of
course great for sneaking around and
Gathering all sorts of information
enemies also wouldn't be able to hit you
although it's not too great for
attacking because you also can't hit
anything yourself while you're in an
Untouchable State though I guess you
could just materialize behind someone
however it's the Awakening of this fruit
that could really unlock its full
potential because if the user awakens
this fruit they could be able to give
their phas ability to any other object
or person around them so let's say if a
friend is trapped in handcuffs you can
just phase them right out of it and this
would be even more more perfect for
let's say a sniper like Uso who could
just make his projectiles pass straight
through walls rematerialize and then hit
the enemies on the other side but now
this next fruit is going to take things
to an entirely new level and that's
because keer summon summon Omi is an
ability that lets you summon creatures
to fight for you in battle and to be
fair this is a fairly common ability
that we've seen in other anime but
essentially this fruit would let you
call out monsters or other types of
creatures to fight for you so a classic
magic user just sits back and uh lets
others fight for them but what's really
cool about this power is that it would
let you start off with some really basic
creatures that you can summon but as you
get stronger and better with the fruit
then those creatures would start
evolving to become terrifying monsters
on the battle fields and another special
ability that makes this fruit even more
unbelievably awesome is that you could
also make make contracts with other
animals and creatures that you find in
the world so that you can then summon
them as well and I mean can you just
imagine a master of this fruit summoning
a whole force of the most powerful
creatures in the world like giant lions
gorillas snakes even sea Kings truly
mastering this fruit makes you an entire
world conquering Army all by yourself
but even summoning an entire Army isn't
as gamechanging a power as the truth
devil fruit submitted by CJ from the
states as well because just like it
sounds this fruit allows you to force
someone to answer your questions
truthfully which is pretty simple yeah
but let's break down how it actually
works first you must make eye contact
with a person and then only can you
activate your powers this basically
forces the person into this trans-like
state where they must answer any of your
questions for at least a short period of
time so yeah for for example let's
remember when this guy casually dropped
a hint about the National Treasure of
marijua and we all desperately wanted to
know more well using our fruit here you
could simply make him tell you
everything that he knows about that
treasure and with this type of
intelligence gathering power you could
basically instantly become one of the
most important people in the entire
world for example just look at this guy
who basically controls the entire
world's newspapers he is such a highly
influential person because he controls
so much of the information that gets
spread around the world but just imagine
how much more you could control the
world if you could find out even more
secret stuff that the world government
or any of the yonko anyone else would
never want to share though I do suppose
that would also make you their number
one target so maybe you should better
keep your power secret but to take this
one step further Awakening this power
would allow you to actually fire kind of
Truth bullets that would force people to
tell you the truth even if you weren't
looking at them however if that doesn't
seem quite powerful enough for you you
can just wait until you hear about this
next fruit which can literally make you
as powerful as a planet and that's
because with the orbit orbit fruit
submitted by oier from Israel you can
manipulate the gravitational pull of
anything that means that instead of
everything naturally being pulled down
to the Earth by gravity you could make
yourself the center of gravity for the
people and objects around you and just
to visualize what this actually means if
you make yourself the center of gravity
that means that things will start to
orbit around you so that rock sitting
over there will now start to rotate
around you and the same goes for people
and other objects so you could have a
ton of stuff and people just naturally
pulling around you like your own little
planets of course you can also make
other things the center of gravity but
where this power of this fruit truly
lies is by being able to quickly change
the center of gravity to confuse
opponents and even change the speeds at
which things are orbiting this would
basically let you gather a bunch of
objects around you and then shoot them
off like missiles so with a fruit like
that that would take a ton of practice
no question but if you can Master it you
would be basically a fighting God but
I'd personally still rather face that
devil fruit in comat bad than this next
one because now we have the t t noi from
Alex hinley otherwise also known as the
terror devil fruit and oh boy does this
one uh give me goosebumps because this
devil fruit allows you to create
Illusions based on your Target's worst
nightmare so let's imagine that you're
in battle and someone is attacking you
well simply activate your Terra powers
and you can give them a heart attack by
scaring them with their greatest fear
literally and Awakening this fruit could
even turn the entire environment around
you into a sort of nightmare realm where
you basically paralyze your opponents
with fear however there is one major
downside here because the Illusions
aren't really physical so they can't
actually attack the person also if your
opponent's worst fear isn't something
all that terrifying like fluffy pink
bunnies or something for whatever reason
then your fruit is basically worth but
still though do keep the fruit away from
me please I mean pure Cinema so before
we dive even deeper into all of the
crazy implications of all of this go get
yourself something to snack and what
better snack to enjoy a fire one piece
chapter with than with today's sponsor
Tokyo treats in case you don't know
that's this amazing snackbox
subscription service directly from Japan
with up to 20 exclusive limited edition
and seasonal flavor Japanese snacks that
even in Japan are only available for a
quite limited time so you know kind of
like one piece chapters that we got this
year now the theme of this very specific
box is very fittingly New Year snacking
party which is of course fitting because
based on all that's been happening in
one piece this year we will also be
clearly snacking on some truly epic
chapters in the new year as well and
this box is filled with snacks inspired
by Japan's oshogatsu or an English New
Year's holiday such as lucky red and
white KitKat aim Moi which is deep fried
Mochi snacks itoen Yos SOA and many many
more though my personal favorite was
honestly these Sesame sweet potato chips
that I basically completely destroyed
before filming this
like like this is literally the last one
and uh like a little snack manga of its
own you also get this booklet here with
the box that explains exactly what you
will receive how everything is related
to Japanese culture and also any
potential food allergies that you might
have if you also want the perfect
Japanese snackbox to enjoy while reading
the perfect Japanese manga then you can
now use my exclusive coat Ohara for $5
of your very first Tokyo treat order
which actually brings me right back to
this amazing rankings however one fruit
that will never be worthless is the ino
in no me submitted by Chris and the idea
with this fruit is that you can empty or
fill up anything and as a very simple
example let's say you were thirsty but
uh your water bottle was empty well with
this fruit you can fill it back up with
your favorite drink or if your fridge is
running low you can fill it up with food
however of course as one major
restriction here is that the things that
you fill up or empty are only temporary
so the changes wouldn't last forever and
now you might be thinking that that's a
pretty weak or mediocre fruit but the
true power of this ability of course
comes when you move from physically
filling or emptying things to doing the
same with abstract concepts for example
what if you filled your enemy's head up
with the idea that they were actually
your ally all along so that they have to
fight with you on the battlefield or say
that someone saw you sneaking into their
Fortress well you could just empty their
memory of ever having seen you so yeah
anytime we get these kinds of creative
abilities they're always just an instant
winner in my head and on that note
actually no one I think can argue that
the snake snake fruit mythical model
boata isn't just simply amazing as well
and this idea from pH minduim from
Brazil s ERS around the mythological
boata creature from Brazilian folklore
basically this is a giant snake with a
few special abilities first the snake is
constantly covered with flames so it has
the ability to manipulate fire and in
addition to that it can create optical
illusions to confuse its enemies what
but the ultimate ability it has is
called the eye Devourer ah which will
allow the user to steal an opponent's
vision from one eye which means that
they are blind in the eyee unless they
can defeat the giant snake within a
certain time period I mean wow is just
such a terrifying and cool ability of a
mythological creature and then on top of
all the other normal benefits of a Zone
fruit you're literally an enormous snake
with unstoppable power and defense which
truly makes this fruit a devastating
combat ability now this next fruit here
though is 100% the most most cursed
ability of this entire video because
Moses defraud from Italy submitted the
dead devil fruit which basically gives
its user a ton of death related powers
that could completely break the one
piece world for example Moses suggests
that this fruit allows the user to both
communicate with the dead and summon
some of the Dead to fight for them and
while for obvious reasons the summoning
part is already ridiculously overpowered
and broken I do think that being able to
communicate with the dead is honestly
quite broken as well I mean just imagine
being able to just talk with the likes
of gold Roger or Joy boy like seriously
just think of all the crazy secrets and
informations that you could learn from
those people however this kind of really
broken ability we simply must give some
restrictions as well so I do think it
would be fair if it could only summon
the dead if you have some sort of part
of their body or skeleton or something
like that plus since summoning the dead
is such a curse ability let's also add
the downside that using this ability
drains your own life force as well which
means the more that you actually use the
power the faster you also die which you
know very fitting for a dead devil fruit
I guess but now prepare yourself because
it's time for maybe the ultimate devil
fruit which is the fruit fruit no me or
as I like to call it just the devil
fruit devil fruit hm because because
just like it sounds this devil fruit
allows you to create other devil fruits
for non-evil fruit users to eat which
honestly I mean is of course such a
broken ability and sounds like an
Unstoppable power for a pirate Captain
to have however you can't just
mass-produce infinite devil fruits
because the fruits that you create are
only temporary plus the more of these
devil fruits that you create at the same
time the weaker they all get
collectively which means if you create
one single lightning fruit for example
will be pretty close in power as the
real one but if you would make let's say
a 100 lightning fruits at the same time
they would all be fairly weak you also
have to consider that the people eating
these fake fruits would be mostly
branded new to these Powers so they
aren't going to be masters of these
powers like most devil fruit users who
actually have been using them for years
and years in the story nonetheless of
course being able to have your crew and
people switch Powers every hour or so
would be insanely cool you do not get
any real abilities for yourself though
so that holds it back a little bit when
compared to the unbelievable Powers
coming up next for example there is
nothing holding back this next fruit
because it is literally the mythical god
of the underworld that's right this is
the human human mythical Zone fruit
model Hades which was submitted by Benji
and in case you don't know Hades is the
Greek god of the underworld and of
course we can't include all of the
underworld's rulers powers in this one
devil fruit since that would just be Way
Way Beyond broken but we can give it the
ability to summon his Guardian
three-headed do curus use his magical
helmet that turns him invisible and you
know maybe some other dark magic
regarding the underworld or the debt
like Reviving people who have just
recently died or something like that and
on top of all that the user of the ha
fruit would become a massive figure kind
of like the Giant Buddha here and of
course being this big God has many
natural benefits including Supernatural
strength and durability so altogether
this is just one incredibly broken
powerful devil fruit however even the
god of the underworld isn't quite strong
enough to compete with this next fruit
which is actually rumored to already be
a thing in the real story because this
is the blow blow fruit yeah no stop
laughing otherwise known as the wind
fruit and there are different versions
of this fruit of course but the one that
hurly from America submitted is
basically a wind loia fruit which turns
you into a wind human that does mean
that your body is now made of wind
allowing you to basically fly in
addition you can of course produce
strong winds to make devastating
tornadoes or wind slashing attacks and
of course this is an unbeatable fruit
when it comes to actually sailing and
traversing the one piece world since you
can just steer your ship anywhere that
you want to go including the com bels
but one thing that makes this fruit even
more impressive is its possible
Awakening because for this fruit and
Awakening would basically allow you to
control the air in the environment and
one possible use of this is that you
could just suck the air out of the area
around someone making it so that they
can't actually breathe which means
seriously don't mess with the air power
which most likely probably has been deat
by Dragon anyways and with these wind
powers we're now truly in the godtier
level abilities and that continues with
the particle devil fruits submitted by
Brett now this insane ability allows the
user to deconstruct and then reconstruct
matter into any shape or form that they
could possibly want remember the build
fruit that we discussed earlier well
this is kind of like that just 10 times
stronger because you can reshape the
resources around you into literally any
shape that you want to put it simply you
can just take a bunch of materials and
break them down into their core elements
and then you can put them back together
however you want for example if you have
a pile of wooden boards you could break
them down and then literally reconstruct
them as one single tree or if you had a
giant Stone Castle you could break it
down and reform it into a giant Stone
Cannon for example or really whatever
you want it as long as it's made out of
stone or maybe even extract the minerals
or the gold from it you know which if
that sounds to you like you might need
50 University degrees to actually use it
you're probably right because it would
take a ton of practice and studying to
not mess this up every time that you had
to put things back together but man once
you have that figured out and you're
somewhat smart this would be an
incredibly powerful and versatile
ability to use anywhere and any time but
now we're finally getting to the fruit
that you've probably all been waiting
for because this was the number one most
submitted fruit in the entire contest
and even though I didn't put it in the
first video we did just have to include
it here and that's of course the water
loia devil fruit and out of the many
many applications I did in the end
choose the one from Umar from Denmark
and it's kind of like it sounds it gives
you the ability to turn your body into
water which lets you move around as a
quick stream of water shoot out bursts
of water or even create a giant flood
wave to dominate a battlefield however I
do have to clarify that this fruit does
not give you the ability to just control
all the water like some people
apparently assume actually looked into
this quite deeply and usually for loas
you can only control the substance that
you actually produce from your own body
so you could only control water that you
produce with your body yourself not
everything around you which is still
incredibly powerful but it's not like
you could just control the entire ocean
or something like that and to be fair it
is kind of debatable if this fruit would
even work in the first place since
obviously water is the main weakness of
devil fruits but assuming that it does
work then it would be obviously an
insane advantage against any other devil
fruit user but even the water fruit is
heart countered by our number two here
which is the seal devil fruit submitted
by wisdom from Nigeria I know this fruit
is not this type of seal here but
instead it allows the user to seal away
anything like trapping it away for
example you could seal a Rushing River
and then release it at the right time or
you could seal a door so no one can ever
open it which honestly sounds kind of
boring until you consider that you can
also seal not only physical things but
abstract things such as memories
movement strength emotions or even devil
fruit abilities which I mean come on if
you can seal those and prevent someone
from using them then this truly is a
Beyond broken fruit now to be fair
wisdom did include some pretty fair
restrictions with this as well though
like you can only seal one thing at a
time and that each seal comes with a
unique condition that's produced that
will actually end up breaking that seal
for example if you seal Luffy strength
then there might be a condition like he
has to do a th000 push-ups to break the
seal and use his strength again that one
was I mean not the best example Maybe
but you get the point which is just
beyond awesome and exactly the kind of
creative devil fruit power idea that I
just love to see however nothing on this
list even the seal fruit is as creative
broken or useful as our number one fruit
which is the author fruit submitted by
Ricardo Cardona from the states because
with this fruit you gain the ability to
summon a magical book and an area of
effect box kind of similar to you know
laws room ability and then any story
that you write into that book becomes
reality within that area of effect so
just to like clarify what that means
let's say you're fighting an insanely
strong opponent and then using your
powers you can just write a short story
including the character which says that
uh they were tragically blinded sometime
in their childhood on their fifth
birthday and then well the magic book
will literally Force reality and the
character to be blind while they are
within the area of effect where
basically they suddenly have been blind
their entire life you get the idea and
how scary that is and what's more
interesting about this fruit though is
that the area of effect starts getting
larger the more skilled the user of the
fruit is So eventually possibly could
even influence an entire Battlefield
like Marine forts however to be fair the
strength of this fruit would also depend
on the user skill with writing stories
because I can just imagine that a simple
story might cause a a weaker effect
while a more complex and better written
story would make the powers way stronger
though to be fair I do wonder what would
happen if let's say the author devil
fruit went up against the mythical
zodiac fruit or if the water devil fruit
user had to fight against the blood
devil fruit and if you want to see
exactly what all those insanely broken
fruits are all about you can watch the
first part of our contest right here
Shanks for watching thanks so much for
submitting all your fantastic ideas if
you want more of these we still have so
many let me know in the comments and I
will see you in the next one